ينضم الينا من باريس جون مارك فيديدا
محامي الفنان سعد المجرد جوماك اهلا بك
معنا في صباح العربيه يسعد صباحك شكرا على
تواجدك معانا نريد ان نعرف منك اكثر
تفاصيل يعني بعد سبع سنوات من بدايه هذه
المحاكمه التي كان مهتم فيها الجميع محكمه
الجنايات في باريس اصدرت حكمه ضد سعد
المجرد ست سنوات سجن بيتهمه الاغتصاب اولا
كمحامي لسعد المجرد كيف تلقيتم هذا الحكم
صباح الخير نحن نعتبر بان الحكم الذي صدر
بحق سعد لمجرد ليس فقط مبالغا فيه او
مفرطا ولكن لا يتوافق مع حقيقه القضيه نحن
نعتبر بانه من خلال اعتبار سعد المجرد
مذنبا فان المحكمه قررت اعطاء الافضليه
لروايه السيد بريو على حساب السيد المجرد
ان المحكمه قررت هذا الحكم بغياب اي ادله
ماديه حول ما حصل في تلك الغرفه الفندقيه
وباعطاء الحسد لروايه وليس لروايه اخرى
لكلام شخص وليس لكلام شخص اخر ان
المجريات الامور اوضحت بان السيد سعد
المجرد كان مليئا بالاحترام للنساء
والاشخاص الذين يتابعونها كل الوقت وهو
نجم ان السيد سعد المجرد واثبت مرارا بانه
شخص غير غنعيف وبان
الخبراء اظهر بانه وبغض النظر عن كل
المجريات بان روايه
او ما حصل مع سعد المجرد لا يتعرض او
يتاثر باي مرض نفسي او وضع نفسي من اي وضع
ان اصدقاء وعائله سعدنا مجرد المقربون
منها واصدقائها
والمعجبون به
يعتبرون ويؤكدون بان ما نسب لسعد المجرد
ليس مثبتا وباننا سنستمر سنستمر في هذه
المعركه لكي يخرج سعد المجرد قريبا من
السجن وان يتابع معركته لكي يتابع عمله
الفني الذي لديه الكثير من المعجبين حول
العالم
سيد جمالك ما هي الحقيقه من وجهه نظركم ما
هي الروايه التي كررتم اكثر من مره اثناء
حديثكم الان معا على الهواء مباشره بانها
لم تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار من قبل المحكمه ما
هي روايتكم اذا
ان الحقيقه بانه عندما لا يكون هناك اي
دليل مادي اي
خبير اي عمل طبي من قبل خبراء
يظهر ويثبت بان روايه السيده روايه حقيقيه
ومنها وبان هذه السيده بعدما قررت ان تاتي
الى شقته او غرفته في الساعه السابعه
صباحا لان نيتها في الواقع هي نيه والله
اعلم بانها كانت تريد ان تكون في علاقه
حميمه عاطفيه مع سعد المجرد ان هذه هي
الروايه التي نحن نؤمن بها هنا دفع عنها
لان سعد لمجرد مره اخرى اكرر ليس شخصا
عفينا بل عنيفا انه شخص
محب وطيب كما في اغنيته شكرا جزيلا
محامي الفنان سعد المجرد